bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
des nombres premiers les nombres
premiers c'est quelque chose qui fascine
les mathématiciens
il ya une bonne raison pour ça c'est un
concept extrêmement simple je crois
qu'on apprend ça au collège
et pourtant ils posent des problèmes
insolubles aux meilleurs chercheurs en
maths du monde et depuis des siècles
alors commençons par rappeler de quoi il
s'agit un nombre premier c'est tout
simplement un nombre entier qu'on ne
peut pas diviser par exemple cet été mon
premier 13 et un nombre premier 21 c'est
un nom premier on peut le diviser par
trois cents noms plus on peut le diviser
par dix évidemment un nombre entier on
peut toujours le diviser soit par un
soin par lui même donc un nombre premier
plus précisément c'est un nombre qui n'a
pas d'autre diviseur que 1 et lui-même
alors pouvait deux têtes à commencer à
chercher les nombres premiers 2 3 5 7 11
13 17 19 etc
c'est simple non et pourtant il existe
des problèmes de maths insurmontable
rien qu'à base de nombres premiers
tenez par exemple tout nombreux pères et
la somme de deux nombres premiers
c'est un mathématicien allemand du
xviiie christian de gaulle barca dit ça
ça lui semblait vrai mais il savait pas
le démontrer
du coup il y en a parlé à leonardo l'air
le plus grands mathématiciens de son
temps peut-être même de tous les temps
euler qui lui a répondu dans un mélange
d'allemand et de latin das ein leader
nommé rousse père machin et ça veut dire
qu'il est absolument certain que ce qu'a
dit gaulle bar est vrai mais il sait pas
non plus le démontrer et bien encore
aujourd'hui personne n'a réussi
personne n'a réussi à démontrer que
n'importe quel nombre pair peut s'écrire
comme la somme de deux nombres premiers
et pourtant tout le monde y croire à
chaque fois qu'on essaye ça marche
chaque fois qu'on prend un nombre pair
on trouve toujours un moyen de le
décomposer comme somme de deux nombres
premiers
par exemple 8 c 5 + 3 12 57 20 17 +3 et
généralement il ya même plusieurs
solutions un vin c'est aussi 13 plus est
aussi loin qu'on regarde ça marche donc
ça doit être vrai et pourtant personne
c'est le montrer quand on a quelque
chose comme ça compense vrai mais quand
c'est pas démontré on appelle ça une
conjecture et donc tout nombreux pères
et la somme de deux nombres premiers
c'est la conjecture de gaulle par ce qui
est fou c'est que plutôt que de vérifier
à la main on peut utiliser un ordinateur
et la conjecture de goldbach
elle a été vérifiée jusqu'à 4 milliards
de milliards c'est à dire que tous les
nombres pairs entre 4 et 4 milliards de
milliards on a trouvé un moyen de les
écrire comme somme de deux nombres
premiers
et voilà on a un problème de maths hyper
facile à comprendre vérifié par
ordinateur jusqu'à des nombre
astronomique et qui pourtant fait damner
les mathématiciens du monde entier
depuis presque trois siècles des
problèmes de ce genre là il y en a plein
d'autres 1 et concerne souvent la
manière dont les nombres premiers sont
répartis tenait entre 0 et 100 on trouve
25 nombres premiers
je les ai mis en rouge entre 0 et 1000
il y en a cent soixante-huit entre 0 et
10 mille
1229 si on met ça en pourcentage on voit
qu'un quart des nombres compris entre 0
et 100 son premier mais seulement 12%
entre 0 et 10 mille c'est à dire que
plus on va loin moins il ya de nombreux
premiers il se raréfient alors on sait
quand même qu'il y en a une infinité sao
clide l'avait déjà démontré il ya plus
de 2000 ans je vous ai par la
démonstration mais elle n'est pas très
très compliqué voyons plutôt une chose
qu'on ne sait pas démontré de temps en
temps on trouve des nombres premiers
avec un écart de 2 par exemple 5 et 7
ou alors 11 et 13 17 et 19 on appelle ça
des nombres premiers jumeaux il y en a
pas beaucoup ils sont aussi de plus en
plus rares est-ce qu'il y en a une
infinité tout le monde pense que oui
mais personne c'est le démontrer on
appelle ça la conjecture des nombres
premiers jumeaux et là aussi avec un
ordinateur on arrive à aller très loin
entre 0 et 1 milliard de milliards on a
trouvé huit cent mille milliards de
nombreux premiers jumeaux mais s'il y en
a vraiment une infinité cette conjecture
des nombres premiers jumeaux on peut en
faire des variantes par exemple on peut
considérer des nombres premiers
consécutif avec un écart de 4 par
exemple 7 et 11 ou alors 13 et 17
on appelle ça des nombres premiers
cousin est ce qu'il ya une infinité de
nombreux premier cousin
on ne sait pas si de nombreux premiers
consécutifs ont un écart de 6 par
exemple 23 et 29 on appelle ça des
nombres premiers sexy alors ça n'a pas
rapport avec le sexe ça rapport avec le
nombre 6 où ils sont drôles ces
mathématiciens et bien là non plus on
sait pas si on a une affinité et on peut
en faire plein des conjectures comme ça
on peut regarder les nombres premiers
consécutive séparé de 14,36 ou 1442 et
chaque fois la question est la même
est-ce qu'il y en a une affinité et on
sait pas et pourtant en 2013 il ya un
progrès spectaculaire qui a été accompli
par un quasi-inconnu it en gang bang a
montré que parmi toutes ces conjectures
avec des écarts de 2 4 6 etc
il y en avait forcément au moins une de
vrai avec un écart plus petit que 70
millions
savard est pas grand chose comme ça mais
ça a complètement débloqué l'étude de ce
problème en quelques mois d'autres
mathématiciens s'y sont mis et ils ont
collectivement réussi à renforcer le
résultat en montrant que en dessous d'un
écart de 246 si on avait forcément au
moins une de correct attention ces
conjectures au fond tout le monde est
convaincu qu'elles sont toutes vraies
mais pour l'instant le mieux qu'on ait
pu démontrer c'est qu'il y en a au moins
une devrait en dessous de 246 l'histoire
de cette découverte est là c'est sympa
quand il a publié sa démonstration
semble travailler dans une petite
université du new hampshire aux états
unis et en fait officiellement il
faisait même pas de recherche il était
juste enseignants
et puis à force de travail solitaire il
a réussi à trouver cette démonstration
il l'a envoyé au meilleur journal
mathématiques du monde qui s'appelle
annals of mathématiques et en quelques
semaines il est devenu une superstar
cette histoire c'est un des rares cas où
on est effectivement à faire un génie
solitaire un peu en marge du système
traditionnel
d'ailleurs le système a pas mis très
très longtemps avant d'accepter ces
travaux donc si jamais parmi vous
certains sont convaincus d'avoir réussi
à démontrer la conjecture de goldbach et
je sais qu'il en a merci d'écrire
directement à annals of mathematics un
pas la peine de m'envoyer la
démonstration en moi
ça peut vous paraître dingue de passer
son temps à essayer de démontrer quelque
chose qu'on a de toute façon vérifié par
ordinateur jusqu'à des milliards de
milliards et dont tout le monde pense
que c'est vrai eh ben je voudrais
terminer sur quelque chose qui a aussi
été vérifié par ordinateur jusqu'à des
nombre astronomique
et pourtant tout le monde pense que
c'est faux je vous ai dit que les
nombres premiers y en a de moins en
moins il sera régi par exemple entre 1
et 100 et en a 25 mai entre 1000 et 1100
il y en a que 16 et entre 3641 à 3740 y
en a que 13 à chaque fois on a un
intervalle de longues heures sans mais
il y en a de moins en moins et en fait
il ya plus de nombreux premiers entre 1
et 100 que dans n'importe quel autre
intervalle de longues heures sans et ça
marche pas que avec 100 si vous essayez
vous trouverez toujours plus de nombres
premiers entre 1 et n que dans n'importe
quel autre intervalle de longueur n
chaque fois qu'on essaye ça marche on
sait pas le démontrer on n'a jamais
trouvé de contre exemple et pourtant on
pense qu'il en existe quelque part et
pour des raisons que je vous épargne
mais dont je parle dans le billet qui
accompagne la vidéo on a un bon portrait
robot du suspect faut savoir que si on
prend n égale 3159 et bien entre 1 et 3
1159 on à 446 nombres premiers et on
pense qu'il existe quelque part un
intervalle de longueur 3159 qui on
comprendrait 447 c'est à dire un de plus
on l'a jamais trouvé ce contre exemple
mais on s'estime et qui doit se trouver
quelque part entre 10 puissance 174 et
10 puissance 1198 on va y a plus qu'à
chercher un au boulot merci d'avoir
suivi cette vidéo si elle vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à la partager comme
toujours vous pouvez retrouver les actus
de la chaîne sur facebook twitter et
vous pouvez me soutenir sur tipis et
pour ceux qui ne sauraient pas encore je
serai à l'espace des sciences à rennes
le mercredi 5 octobre donc on aura
l'occasion de se voir là bas si vous y
êtes